your mom a lot of what made really what
made your career possible was it your
mom won a green card lottery isn't that
right that's right and had that not
happened and you not been able to travel
do you think any of this would have
happened for you
of course not yeah that's the thing
about the situation that we have now
with the refugees or yeah you know I
think these people are the victims you
know yes the wars and you know
everything that's going on so if we ban
them right if we ban people you know
it's we just stick to hope you know the
American dream so I think now it's very
it's really important when people like
you who have had been able to do such
beautiful work are able to say to other
people this was my experience this is
what was able to happen for me because I
was allowed to come to this country
right now obviously that's a big
discussion a lot of arguments here in
the United States about it but obviously
your experience you know shows us that
something really positive can come from
bringing people here most definitely and
I'm not the only example there's yeah
plenty of examples and it's just that's
just you know how I would do it yeah and
that's how is the American Way yeah that
was been done on this country was formed
by refugees so you know this is just to
keep it going
yeah yes
you